@@@Second Thought @@@
What would you give to have perfect eyesight a faster metabolism
To be a few inches taller or more muscular
For most of history we've had to deal with the genetic hand we've been dealt and a lot of times
That's not much fun
genetic disorders diseases and inadequacies have plagued our species for thousands of years
But what if we could change all that the answer may be closer than we think?
after a quarter of a million years of slow natural evolution
humanity's on the cusp of having the ability to edit the very building blocks of our being in the past few decades
We've developed tools that help doctors and expecting parents to anticipate any serious health conditions their child may have
such as hereditary diseases and Down syndrome to
Some people these tests already raise ethical red flags as in many cases especially outside the United States
The majority of women choose to terminate their pregnancy if the warning signs of Down syndrome are detected as our technology advances
We'll be able to move from detection of these conditions to removal the first step down the road to so-called designer babies
The hope or concern is that soon enough we'll graduate from selecting out the bad genes to selecting in more favorable ones
This is where many people begin to cry eugenics and advocate extreme caution
most people would probably agree that
eliminating diseases like Huntington's or quality of life disabilities like poor eyesight would be a good thing and some even suspect that not
Editing out these genes would constitute an ethical failure in the future
But what about giving your child a leg up on the competition by sprinkling in traits like increased height, or musical proficiency or above-average intelligence?
While the technology to do, this is on its way, we're not there just yet
And it's expected to be very expensive at least at first you might think well if you've got the money for it
And it's legal
Why not you're just giving your child the best shot at a successful life
Consider the following scenario a wealthy couple decide they want to enhance their baby's genes
the average woman typically has 15 eggs extracted for an in-vitro fertilization procedure
Those 15 potential children will likely differ in IQ by about 20 to 30 points
The parents will be able to select the child or children with superior intelligence to carry to term
Doesn't seem like that big of on the surface, but what happens when the top 10% of society can afford the procedure
But the rest of the population can't now you have a society divided not only by the rapidly increasing wage gap
But also by a new intelligence gap with wealthy children being far more likely to succeed than the 90 percent below them this would further
Stratify our world into the haves and have-nots with modified people only marrying and reproducing with other Modifieds
Thus keeping their gene pool more desirable the solution for this type of situation would be to make genetic modification accessible to all people
Giving everyone the ability to at least screen out disease and disabilities like poor eyesight
But when we begin to dabble in aesthetic or additive modifications we get to the real dilemma of genetic engineering
Just because we can do something doesn't necessarily mean we should do it
First comes the issue of deciding what this perfect human would look like if we learned anything from Germany during World War two it's that
When one group dictates what features are best it can cause some serious
problems when parents can start designing their ideal babies like a piece of custom furniture
There's a real danger that people will become competitive adding modifications in a never-ending quest to build the ultimate human child
Then of course, there's the fact that our technology is rarely infallible
What happens when a couple orders a six foot four Greek god of a child and he only grows up to be six foot one?
Could they demand a refund
Would they feel cheated out of the product they ordered how would their child feel about being considered inferior?
And how would society treat him?
then there's the
international angle China is already known for its questionable social engineering
Practices such as limiting families to one child and taking children away from their parents to be enrolled in Olympic training schools in an attempt
to build future champions
It doesn't take much imagination to assume that in a country like that genetic modification would be seen as a very good thing
Parents wouldn't have to worry about their one child being insufficient. They could order a smart strong handsome
Male who would grow up to take care of his parents just like they'd always wanted
Olympic training schools would be packed with modified children suited to each event
greater lung capacity and endurance for distance runners a smaller leaner built for gymnasts
longer limbs for swimmers when other countries use genetic modification to gain a competitive edge whether in sports or other more serious
Applications, what are the rest of us to do it would be harmful to allow ourselves to be made non-competitive
But what would it cost to keep up it would be expensive of course?
But extreme genetic engineering may also cost us some of our humanity and of course
There's the potential for unforeseen health consequences to arise and modify children
DNA is incredibly complex and many traits aren't simply a one gene switch
What happens when we accidentally negate a gene that protects against the disease we have no experience with tinkering with systems
We don't fully understand is a good way to end up in big trouble at the end of the day
We have some important questions to consider when the technology is widely available will we have an ethical responsibility?
To modify our children to prevent disease or disability
Or is that just a part of being human? Let us know your thoughts in the comments below
You may have noticed second thought has a shiny new logo if you like the look of it come check out our new merch store
And preorder a t-shirt or vinyl stickers, they'll be shipping in about three weeks
so now's your chance to be the cool kid on the block and get them first as an added bonus just for being awesome the
first 50 people to visit standard TV
Second thought will get 10% off their entire order that includes purchases from some of our other favorite creators - like Wendover productions real engineering
And crypts cos act so be sure to visit our merch store using the link below and get 10% off your order today
Remember to subscribe if you haven't already smash that Bell and check out these videos next as always
Thanks for watching, and we'll see you next week